Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're going to go ahead and take those layered materials
and even show you how to adjust a few things to be able to get to different parts of those
materials and textures to be able to get different looks, we're going to put those
all in the parent material, and we can actually see what our final output is going
to be.
So let's get started.
So one thing I want to point out is you saw that we connected our RGB on that
last layer material, and we went in here and we controlled it in such a way and I should
say with our layer blend material, that we grabbed the RGB into the channel.
Now you can, as my example shows, you can use the green channel if you want, or the
red channel, it depends what you want to mask out.
Because if we double click on this texture, we can actually see different values.
Let's pull this across and dock it here.
You can see different values and strengths that may occur in each one of these channels.
Now this guy's pretty black and white.
But we're going to grab some of that information, according to what we need.
Now you can even bring in a color one is can have mass channels in here for packing.
That also can be a great way to be able to optimize things.
If you're not familiar with that, you got to kind of dial back a little bit back to
when we talked about our materials and I believe the second material class that you had,
and I showed you how to pack UVs, we can actually paint into each UV channel, I can
paint into the green channel, I can paint in the blue, I can paint into any channel
that I choose.
And it actually makes it pretty easy.
In our particular case, because there's probably a bit more of a stronger texture in here,
we're going to go and grab or a contrast, we're going to go and grab the green and
put it into the channel.
He's a black and white, so it really doesn't have a lot going on in his channels.
But again, I wanted to point that out that you can pack these in such a way and you can paint
on a different channel, bring it in here and use that as an alpha, which can be genius
and save a bit of time, especially if you're recycling, reducing and reusing that texture
on several different levels.
That actually can work pretty well to your advantage.
Let's go and apply.
And let's go ahead and go to our parent material.
So if we go back to the folder that we created, and we'll go to work demo, and we'll
go to our parent material here, there we go demo parent, let's double click on that
he's off screen, let me pull him over.
So what we need to do is need to adjust a few things.
So we can use this parent material to our advantage.
Now again, the one thing I do want to keep, I want you to keep in mind, when you're
working with these material layers and materials, just make sure you're keeping things
a bit organized.
And what I mean by that, you want to make sure that you know where everything's at any
particular place.
And you want to make sure that you're not making these.
I mean, you can make the layers pretty complicated.
Like I said, try to pack textures when you can, and try to be very deterministic of what
you need.
You don't want to necessarily bog these layers down in a particular material, because
it doesn't optimize things.
And in fact, it doesn't make it lighter.
It just makes things a little bit more easier to use and organize.
So it doesn't lower the size of the material per se.
Keep that in mind.
Alright, so I just want to emphasize that point because it's really important to consider
those things.
So what we need to do now, let's go ahead and make a material attribute layer.
So material attribute layers, there it is.
And we want to collapse this because we're going to make sure that we're using the information
jumping into here, and not using anything erroneous or extra here, because we really
are not deriving anything from the original nodes that are set up.
We're going to be using the nodes that we build on our material layers and material
blend.
So I'm going to go ahead and click on that or click on the grid.
And we're going to say, hey, use material attributes.
And we're going to pull this right into here.
Now what we want to do is go into material attributes and do some adjustments.
We'll see at the top here that we have a default layers.
So let's click on this once and open this up.
You'll see that we have two slots, we have one for our background, and then one
for our layer.
And we're going to mainly focus on that for our example.
We got to remember the names of our stuff, there's quite a bit of things in here.
So let's go ahead and load and load what our background is going to be.
This is going to be a material layer.
So we'll just load this as the tile.
So we'll type this in ml underscore new tile area, grab that.
And then we're going to need that layer that's going to be on top, that's going
to be our grudge.
So we're going to click on this, we're going to go to ml underscore new grudge.
There you go, click on that.
Now we're going to need our blended material.
So let's get that blend asset.
The one we made was ml be do demo.
So let's go and type that in ml be underscore new demo.
There it is right there.
So cool.
So we have this all set up now.
And we are ready to go.
Now again, we can add more layers here or in the instance.
And what I mean by that is let's actually find this guy.
Let's right click, upset, apply, make sure it applies.
There we go, updates it.
Right click on it.
And we're going to say create a material instance.
In this material instance, typically you can put MI or put INST.
Sometimes they leave INST.
It just depends on how big my name is.
If it's really long, I'll just do MI.
So I'll double click on this.
Let's pull this over.
There we go.
And in here, we can see our background, our layer asset, and we can open up all the
things that we have in place.
Pretty cool.
There's our layer, there's our scalar values and normal grime intensity.
We didn't put it in a group.
That's why it didn't show up.
We have a contrast grunge, contrast intensity for that.
But we don't have anything for the foundation for the tiles, which is totally fine.
So now we can go in here and we can adjust some of these.
And if we want to, there's a quick button here to be able to add another element.
So you can actually add a quick material layer and then populate it if you've already
created those MLs or material layers ready to go.
So let's go and see it in our scene.
I'm going to move this over.
It's really just going to replicate what we have here.
And I think I might have even flipped them in here where the base is the grunge and the
layer is the brick.
You can totally do that or tile I should say it's up to you.
Let's go and find this guy.
Let's apply him to our scene.
There we go.
Drag him on there.
And then now we can control our contrast if we want to.
Oh, nice.
We can control our grunge amount.
We can believe that through.
Pretty cool.
Either way works great.
This one's a little bit crisper with the defined edges.
This one does a little bit more blending and may work for you.
It's actually I kind of like what it's given us.
So it's not too shabby.
So we can increase that or decrease it.
That's up to you.
How you want to do it kind of fades nicely into each other.
So you can see that we're still using that alpha information getting bits and parts of
that grunge coming through.
Cool.
So that's it with this one.
Hopefully you learned a lot on the new way to be able to create your layer blends.
What we're going to do in the next video is we'll take a look at NPCs and see how
they work.
Thanks again.